well we've been joined by two youngsters
with differing views on the appeal or
lack of it of politics they are casi
Galpin and Adelle Rosalyn and were also
joined live from Atlanta in the United
States by the comedian Eddie Izzard
Cassie to you first what do you think
about politicians do they really
understand young people do they engage
with you according to the research that
go gliding have done girls don't think
that politicians listen to them enough
so it's really important that when we're
launching a set of calls for the
government really listening to girls in
the general election that they really
stand up and take notice of what girls
across the country are saying okay so
that's what they need to do for girls
what do they need to do for young people
in general I think generally they just
have to go out go onto the streets go
out to the university speak to them or
find out what really motivates them and
how they can help them our views our
ideas our so-called policies I think
stay with us we're going to talk to you
a little bit more in a moment let's just
get the views of Eddie Izzard live from
Atlanta Eddie you've said you want to
get into politics what would you do for
young people to help them engage I think
one has to inspire young people I think
this is what the politicians and as of
trying to be a future politician need to
do you need to have a worldview that can
inspire people who are young and
probably feel that in their twenties and
thirties they may not be really getting
in to being able to change the how the
way the world or the country works but
you need to aspire you need have a
vision for a future that actually grabs
people's minds I don't know if that is
happening enough Russell Brand has said
he's never voted there's no point in
voting and that certainly seems to be a
view that is shared by a lot of the
young people today who who really don't
feel that their voices are being heard
or will be listened to well I disagree
with Russell I think I think the trouble
is politics is very complex that is
unfortunately the situation it is that
complex and we need to get it and
simplify it I think the extremist
parties come up with a very simplistic
politics which I disagree with but real
politics center right center left it is
actually very complex but you
need to inspire the younger generation
you need to inspire young people bring
the voting age down to 1617 you know
this is this is something would be more
positive and I think the something if
you take like the Olympic Games which
isn't a vertical itical but young people
involved in that people of all ages were
involved in that I was very keen and
happy to be involved in it and that was
great to see everyone working together
with a mission people need a mission and
if you can have a vision of the future
that actually goes somewhere that's
positive I think that will appeal more
to young people Eddy I'm just going to
put a couple of your points to our
panelists and others here and adult and
Eddie was talking there about lowering
the voting age to 16 or 17 we've seen
that in Scotland in the Scottish
referendum there's been a lot of
engagement in that age group do you
think that would work here I think it's
a great idea yes you should lower it for
1617 improve citizenship classes make
perhaps politics more engaging and
perhaps a compulsory in schools and
inform them as to how they can help in
their local area as well as the regional
and the wider area in the UK politics in
schools is something that's come up
repeatedly throughout the day and
through our contributors that on the
stand up be counted up as well that
people aren't being taught politics in
schools so how are you expected to know
who to vote for when you turn 18 well
you just don't and you're so
disillusioned by it by the time you
reach the age that you are actually able
to make difference and vote that you
just have no idea about what you should
vote for but the thing is young people
are more connected than ever so why
don't we tap into that and so
politicians should ideally link in to
that and try and get their voice try and
get young people's voices heard by the
politicians yeah let's just put that to
Eddie Izzard young people are tapped in
the technology is there politicians need
to do more to engage in a social media
sense absolutely they do I should add to
this the way figures were coming up to
this election if people feel who are
young people they want to be involved
become activists you can get out there
you could be on the streets you could be
meeting people who are activists and
trying to make a change in whichever
party you join so there is the
opportunity there in coming up to next
May's general election for young people
to
get out but sometimes it's really
difficult to choose exactly what you
feel and I didn't join the political
parties till I was 35 but yes social
media absolutely it engages young people
and then you have to put this vision on
top you have to have a vision of the
future that it's going to inspire people
you're talking to us from the United
States President Obama of course had a
lot of young people involved in his
presidential campaign how did he manage
that and how what difference did it make
well he was a black man running to be
the first black president in the United
States of America and that really got
through to people it was a different
thing I think he's had great difficulty
then trying to put all the policies he'd
like into action because the extremists
on the right wing the Tea Party
particularly were just trying to stamp
down and make him not be able to do
anything but he has struggled hard to
push through agenda with his health care
which they disparagingly called Obama
care but now in the Democratic Party
they they say we love Obama care and
that's it's taken so long for that to
happen we got that in 1945 in Britain
and they've only just got that through
in the last year so here in America do
you think part of the problem though is
is that our politicians don't have the
right charisma charisma is a you can't
buy it from a shop it's a tricky old
thing and that goes hand in hand with
inspiration you tries to try and lead by
example I mean I you know I'm very
positive on Europe I believe Europe is
an adventure if you have the guts to go
for it I'm now touring France in French
touring Germany and German just started
Spanish then I want to do Russian there
is a way of doing things I came out as a
trans as being a transvestite when I was
23 and I've been open and honest about
that since then and so you've got to try
and come up with ideas which are game
changes which changed the way that
people live their lives in a positive
way I hope and that's what I've tried to
do and I think other politicians need to
do that as well honesty is a word there
Eddie Izzard was using that's one of the
words that's come up in all of our polls
that people value the most young people
particularly value the most in our
politicians what do you think of when
you think of today's politicians cancer
we do inevitably think of just the guys
at Westminster it's not varied enough we
need well I would argue that we did war
women in politics more young people
because that way the David Clemens
reshuffle do anything for you well that
is probably another whole whole debate
I'd say and that we just I think we just
need that the politicians need to reach
out through young people because they
make up such a large number of the
population that just currently isn't
really reached or targeted when you look
at Prime Minister's Questions and you
see the shouting that some would call it
the stuffiness others would describe it
does that engage young people it can
appear a fast sometimes but it is a bit
engaging you can see that they are human
on earth they are human like us they are
passionate in some sense that it is out
of hand a few times I've sat in PM cues
from the gallery and it is a bit of a
farce you do lose concentration you kind
of lose the meaning of the point that
they're there so it's a mixed bag really
and I think it does need a bit of
reining in the speaker does have to do a
better job okay let's just get a final
thought from Eddie Izzard here as we
start to move towards the 2015 election
Eddie Izzard what advice would you give
to Mr Cameron Mr Miliband Mr Clegg to
make sure that they do engage with young
voters inspire a generation that's what
they've tried to do in the Olympics and
I think they did it yes you've got to be
inspirational you've got to have a
vision and then you fight your corner I
suppose but yes it needs to appeal to
young people and I think vision is the
thing okay Eddie Izzard Cassie Galpin
and a tall resident thanks very much
indeed for your thoughts